à mes 18 ans j'ai pris ma première carte
à l'UMP je me suis engagé comme militant
j'ai gravi tous les échelons je me suis
devenu grâce à la confiance de Christian
Jacob secrétaire général des
républicains et je sais à quel point
notre famille politique militante a
besoin demain à sa tête d'un homme qui a
été maire engagé et qui a su porter des
combats difficiles il nous faut un
combattant nous n'avons plus le droit au
chamailleries aux divisions au règlement
de compte il est peut-être temps de
faire en sorte que notre famille
politique prenne le plus beau risque ce
risque c'est l'audace il est temps de
tourner les pages faire en sorte que
demain vous soyez fiers d'être
représenté par celles et ceux qui
rassemblaient parleront à tous les
Français la seule droite qui valent
c'est la Droite populaire